[Music]
what is this true I am a big believer
that it's not healthy to keep anything
inside if you can laugh at something
weird or embarrassing about yourself
you'll never be ashamed and with that in
mind let's enjoy the following segment
that we like to call audience
[Music]
[Applause]
oversharing let's welcome our first
audience oversharer
Catherine green everybody Catherine
thank you for playing audience over here
I know it's a little weird you know
sharing awkward things but if I'll read
yours
you can read mine it's that okay well so
I will go first
Catherine green when I was a kid I
thought the marshmallow mam Stay Puft
from Ghostbusters lived in my backyard I
thought he was going to get me in my
sleep to this day I still can't sleep
with the windows open if I'm alone not
the Satanic devil dogs to the writer
left
demon woman the cartoon why is he
smiling what's he up to
coward it's gonna be okay that's a good
overshare thank you I think you just
have to think positive things and he'll
go away though I hope so right yeah I
mean my boyfriend didn't even know until
today so it's a little sorry that sounds
a lot like a deal-breaker
JK what's his name okay Chris lighten up
so why don't you read mine Katherine
please the first girl I ever French
kissed crystal crystal said I didn't
know you were going to stick your tongue
in my mouth it was a camp and we kissed
and as she was pulling away she went
thank you so much Catherine everybody
thank you this is our next audience over
here eight women box I said that right
right they had to come up and then go
it's like off but with Gigi thank you
for coming up here
alright let's let's trade over shares
and I will read yours kaitland yes there
we go Caitlyn was I was once pulled over
under the suspicion of drunk driving and
failed the sobriety test even though I
was completely 100% sober that's tricky
you're nervous and they're like what's
over there I was raised to look officers
of the law
in the eye mug shot so what do you what
do we got from me that I think yours is
bad when I was a kid I one time told my
mom to promptly throw her Victoria's
Secret catalogs away as soon as she was
done with them because they were causing
me to stumble
[Laughter]
sprays religious and I you know that's
code for put away the bra catalogue cuz
I'm jerking it more than I'd like
[Applause]
[Music]